i have at least considered creating an
only fans account
i very not only have i considered it
we've had fairly high level talks at
daily wire
[Music]
i could not possibly be more excited to
be playing this game
yes or no
with a woman after my own heart
a woman who needs no introduction
a woman who has the same drink that i
have
gina carano
gina thank you so much for coming on the
game thank you for having me now people
are going to be very envious obviously
that i get to play this game with you
right now but you too
can play the yes or no game you can do
it at home because daily wire is
merchandising absolutely everything
right now cue the dramatic orchestral
music pour yourself a drink you can play
the most important game of daily wire
yes or no you'll be able to put
your knowledge of your friends and
family to the test bring home the game
where the rules are completely made up i
have no idea how to play even though
we've done it many many times it's
available this coming fall you can
pre-order the game right now over at
dailywire.com
shop
shall we begin yes we should all right
gina because that was quite the
introduction i mean i want one now i we
can make it happen can i go home with
that one yeah certainly don't have to
win it right i think you have to win
okay now you're a lady okay ladies go
first so i just pick it up and read it
yeah you pick it up read it and then
i still don't totally get the rules but
i think
i move your martini
based on how i think you would answer
the question and you move my martini
based on how you think i would answer
the question and then whatever happens
we drink so we're judging each other yes
this is a game of judgment
we're bringing back judgments okay
i've watched a full episode of the
michael knowles show wow
this is a real and it's a full episode
obviously who wouldn't i mean that seems
so simple i guess my my answer on this
is pretty obvious oh yeah i mean you
look you look like you like to look at
yourself
i'm just kidding
um
do we have to tell the truth absolute
honesty oh shoot okay lies
um drink
wow
well you know actually in fairness
i think you have to drink too i'm not
sure that i've ever why would i watch i
mean i've been in
and then we'll have to stop it you're
not telling the truth
why would i watch it i already know what
i said we both got it wrong we both have
to okay all right
cheers maybe should we get my show
playing in the background so we can
rectify this terrible
error
maybe afterwards
i'm so sorry i it's a good martini i
need to watch it
you know
listen on the on the ride home you're in
nashville for the premiere of terror on
the prairie yeah but on the ride home
you've got the whole back catalog a
thousand awful right now
should i drink twice you might be you
might be i think you're the only person
in the country who hasn't seen i have a
show but you know i'm gonna buy like 10
of these for all of my family i'm gonna
make up for that it's a mistake okay
okay i can't believe i don't believe
your answer though we need a lie
detector test yeah let's go
that's a follow-up game yeah
for getting a job after college the only
the only degree more useless than
psychology is getting one in italian
literature ouch
[Laughter]
can you geometrically only
oh oh
okay
you're totally right i know that's what
i would say but did i get it wrong yes i
did
what would be the more useless majors um
well
i majored in psychology well i didn't
graduate yeah i had a feeling
um
so did you get this are you right
i got it wrong yeah
but you got me right right so you
actually don't have to drink okay but
you got me right but i had one of my
majors was italian literature i find it
very useful yeah especially in my single
days
back in my single days in my wayward
youth i would find you know if i like
how you talk my way where do you in my
way where is my derelict
i'm going to start using that oh my
wayward use but i go gina i am not i'm
not the sort of guy that you would find
at an mma fight you know i wasn't
captain of the football team so whatever
luck i could have
it had to be talking yeah you know a
little dante yeah little petrarch
amazing that was very useful if i had
majored in something else it wouldn't
even have that so what kind of guy do
you find at a mma fight yeah
i don't know i mean have you ever been i
haven't been
but i assume people are speaking a
little more with their fists than with
their you know um what's interesting
about fighting is like it's just so it's
its own language so
it's also i promise you should drink
again i'll drink again i've heard also
that it can be very cerebral in terms of
trying to game out 100
you know 1000 cerebral yeah i um i have
you know i used to do krav maga because
jeremy boring the god king of daily wire
he forced me to okay we would do it we
would do in the morning he said he's
showing up before work we're going to do
krav maga at the time i called it krav
maga it was the trump year yeah amazing
or jiu jitsu that was the other one you
know because it's the israeli forces
they train that way yeah so i did it but
i was never i was never any good at it
yeah well yeah it takes a while it takes
about six months just to like
i guess get out of the awkward phase
yeah just like anything i never made it
out yeah okay so now do did i just go or
you go yes oh no okay
all right
often men and women can be close or even
best friends without ever wanting to
cross the lines
you're old-fashioned right pretty
old-fashioned i think that you would say
no yeah you're right okay but what would
you say you think that i would say i
would think that you would say no you
strike me as a fairly old-fashioned
fashioned yeah
um
i would say yes you would say yes
i would say you think often men and
women can be totally platonic friends
and not have any
desire to yeah a hundred percent like
yes wow i mean my whole life i've been
around boys and um
at least coming from my perspective well
there's a kick there's another maybe
from the gina standpoint there's no but
do you think all all your male friends
they've never had any thought
me and gina what could be
i don't know i don't know how men think
i i really don't even pretend i'm just
like that's better that's better yeah so
i don't know how i feel and i feel like
i can be a hundred percent yeah
absolutely i think that i think you're
probably right about you yeah but i
don't know if you're right about the man
i think the man may be listening well
then so then you're drinking because you
got it wrong because i got it wrong yes
i want to get more wrong by the way
you're too good at the game you know i
think i'm i don't really know how the
scoring works i think i've been
undefeated in this game
probably until now gina i'm playing so
poorly
you should go again
okay as long as you put on this box the
rules don't rules don't matter they're
completely fake and if they're real i
don't know what they are and that'll be
my review on this
this game okay
though it's a toss-up personally i would
feel more at risk hanging out one-on-one
with amber hurd than i would if i had to
take a meeting with harvey weinstein
oh that took a turn okay
sorry this is your answer okay so
personally i would feel more at risk
hanging out one-on-one with amber heard
than i would
if i had a good meeting with
harvey weinstein i'm gonna say that you
um
are gonna say yes to that
yes
you would be more at risk hanging out
with i wouldn't i would because i'm not
harvey's type as far as i can tell
i'm not in his industry there's not much
he can do to me yeah amber heard she
could
boil my rabbit i mean that woman she
could destroy uh truly could destroy a
man's life yeah now did i get yours
right so
i don't feel at risk with either one i
think they would be at risk
to be quite honest so i don't know how
to
it's a margin call so i have to say who
would i be more at risk with amber heard
or harvey weinstein or
gosh neither one of them
they'd both be in danger they would be
endangered they should be the ones they
would be unreal so it's the question are
you at risk the answer is just no yeah
no no never okay that's good so we both
got it right okay okay okay
that's funny that i would but certainly
you know you think i guess now though if
i had a meeting with harvey weinstein
would be separated by you know steel
bars so it'd probably probably be okay
now too gosh but you wouldn't want that
energy no i don't i don't need that
sometimes i wish they would have had me
take that meeting i think i cancelled on
it and i was just like no did you did
you get an um yeah like like they always
they were like the agency was always
like we need to have you meet this guy
and i was like i think i cancelled once
and then i had to get reset up um but
i have this and i wish they would have i
have this vision of you meeting with
harvey weinstein and then you know smash
cut weinstein is just defenestrated out
of the beverly hills hotel or something
yeah
yeah
i mean
i never understood the whole me too
thing because i was just like you could
just say no just get up and walk out he
shows up in his bathrobe you say no
thanks buster yeah just say no yeah just
no is a complete sentence
oh that's a good line yeah okay fine i
stole it from tyler but it's good well
just say no was from nancy reagan but
they're both good lines yes okay
wrestling someone of the same sex is 100
straight if you say no homo before you
begin
i'm not as expert in the rules of
wrestling but so wrestling some of the
same sex is 100 straight as long as you
say
no homo before you begin
ginagina
so you think
it's a hundred it is 100 straight
scientifically proven as long as you say
no homo you could these are the rules of
the schoolyard you could kiss another
man right on the lips and whisper into
his ear i love you as long as you say no
homo beforehand this has gone back to
first grade i feel like that makes it
more homo
because you're raising the idea
as though it was not in anyone's mind
yes i think it makes it a little bit
more like hey i'm not checking you out
well you know
like hey don't think about zebras yeah
yeah exactly yeah exactly okay well
you may have persuaded me uh-huh but you
still answered wrong so i think that
means you have to drink wait what i
answered you answered wrong because you
guessed my answer wrong even though you
probably right right you made the better
argument okay
that's how this game works i guess all
right
i guess i guess i think maybe
all right now
you're up
okay i have at least considered creating
an only fan's account
at least consider this is not saying you
went through the steps it's just i've at
least considered considered it
how well do you think you know me
consider like the idea
you're correct never in my life have i
ever considered it gina
you are incorrect
i very not only have i considered it
we've had fairly high level talks at
daily wire
we have not now i wasn't gonna
strip down too much to my skimmies too
much not too much you know okay people
need a little something yeah my idea was
what if you started in only fans but
instead of you know twerking or whatever
you just
read poetry or something or you just you
know uh played ukulele or you just i
don't know yeah i mean does only fans
have to be all about sex i don't know i
don't think so you know why because i
don't know because i've never even been
on only fans yeah see this is the issue
with only fans
i have never you know what you know why
though i'm not saying had i had i been a
young wayward youth when only fans came
out yeah who knows i don't know who's to
say but thankfully i became an old man
sort of before only fans happened yeah
but here was my problem with with
starting one through the daily wire wait
you never answered have you been no i've
never been i can say 100 with 100
certainty i think this box needs to be
attached to a lie detector test let's do
it please plug in my polygraph and that
can be my version of the game and we can
split the person and we're all just
hammered yeah
but i had i had this problem which is if
i started my only fans of ukulele
playing and tap dancing or whatever yeah
i would still be
leading people to a website that hosts a
ton of forms right right so that would
that would still be wrong right
yeah so you have to drink yeah wait
because you got you answered wrong
oh because you're gonna okay all right
shoot well this is great i know i like
to lose this can you
can you imagine how enticed the audience
is right now thinking about
the prospect of you my only family yes
yes
i mean
it could do well do you think i could do
it i'm going to put that blurb at the
top of my future only
it could do well gina carrano
okay now i'm up okay
any public parade or march that includes
kink or nudity should be illegal in the
united states
any public parade or march kink
kink define uh yeah that's there is the
trick the devil's in the details yeah i
think so they're talking about like a i
guess like a pride parade or like uh
or like some some pride parades with the
guys in the leather and the whips and
everything yeah
should be illegal uh
in the united states
gina you're going to be speaking in
cursive very soon
i
i certainly do listen what people want
to do in the privacy of their own
streets of their own privately owned
streets is i suppose none of my business
but i don't it is kind of weird now
you've got all these parades yeah guys
in leather and paddles and like demon
looking people in in costumes and
men with appendages that they shouldn't
even have yeah dancing it's i'm hey i'm
against it i i can be like not pro like
i don't have to go to these things yeah
but you don't think they should be
banned i do feel like there's a fine
line of like taking people's um freedoms
away from them yeah and also i always
thought it would just be hilarious if
there was like a full nude protest like
there was every protest in the world in
2020 and i was like get the nude one
going that'd be hilarious only
only just because would be hilarious
other than that yeah i mean i think that
people you know but like i don't want to
take other people's freedoms away you
want to say no to them were you in la
during this would have been 2018 or 17 i
want to say there was a a protest called
the free the nipple protest yeah
so i was sent down on assignment from
the daily wire i'm not joking oh i sent
down an assignment to
investigate this no and i thought i
thought feminism is the greatest trick
that men ever played on women we
convinced all of these
frequently though not uniformly
attractive women to just dance around
naked in the streets and all these men
are there and they say you go girl yes
that's feminism you're down with the
patriarchy yeah i think
well
i think the you know i think the world
has a really good way of making the most
beautiful things ugly yeah and it's like
sexuality is really not a bad thing it's
a really beautiful thing
and so it's like the mystery i think is
so sexy sexy equals mystery to me those
things go hand in hand
so it's like like put
keep the nipple sacred
you know that's such a good point yeah
like it's like the mystery of it all is
like what makes things sexy and the
image the role of the imagination
this is why generally speaking
lingerie is more enticing than just
people kind of put it all out there yeah
or just like even like the sex scenes
nowadays are just so blatant and you're
just like dude i did not want to have
that in my face
when you've got like the top gun like
the top gun the first one yeah um sex
scene and it's like the lighting and
it's just like insinuating more yeah
somebody getting banged in like game of
thrones you know like you're like geez
but sort of like on the opposite side
the opposite side of the you know
experience of sensuality yeah in
hitchcock you don't see the big scary
thing yeah you it's alluded to it's it's
implied but and so your imagination does
all this work yeah whereas if you you
know if you just see people sort of
bumping uglies right in front of your
face yeah you're like
yeah that's not that you're right that's
a great point but you still haven't read
it
[Music]
i answered wrong i always i forget the
question now you keep answering right
but you keep getting my answer wrong oh
shoot because you would be
pro taking that freedom away from taking
it all away i'm taking all i want i'm
leaving everything today hey i want the
pedophiles off the streets but like we
can make other rules for that for the
pedos yeah yeah that's maybe that's the
later question yeah okay in solidarity
because that was such a good it's such a
good point thank you on imagination
sensuality even desire you know desire
desires are good things yeah you've got
to be ordered in the right way that's
why porn is toxic it's like you're not
using your imagination you're shutting
yourself down at your brain and you're
not using your sentence your senses
right i mean the idea
sex is is great in many ways but it's
not physically it's great but it's also
pointing to to something beyond the
physical you're well you're sharing your
soul yeah you're giving yourself
entirely to someone else and then i'm
like no not me
like wait a second what am i doing that
for no but you i mean you're really you
know you're in porn it's just like okay
well we're both just
sacks of flesh you know
this is not an olympic sport
this is art
yeah gina you're right this game is
rigged it is this game is wrecked i keep
going
okay
neither is on the level but
hypothetically speaking and in straight
strict weight classes it is more of a
fair fight for a woman to fight a
transgender woman
a male than it would be for a woman to
fight another woman who is absolutely
juiced out of her mind
steroids example rhymes with rybar
rhymes with someone i fought once in my
life who may or may not have taken some
oh for sure performance enhancing yeah i
was pretty sure she did but um she's
such a sweetheart though so so the
statement is it's it's you know a
transgender woman so this could be a guy
maybe he's taking hormones maybe he's
not right it's it's a fairer fight for
the woman to fight him than to fight a
woman who's juiced out of her mind on
some other i mean it's cut
yeah it's kind of hard to parse the two
because there's a lot of similarity but
i would still say
i would still say that you would say
yeah no yeah in a way right i fought
both in my life and um
you know
uh that's what that's one thing i don't
get about the whole like you can't it's
just not fair it's not even close it's
not even close men punch differently
that's why when i punch people are like
you hit like a man
but i still don't hit
like exactly exactly like a man you know
um it's just people people don't know
this and i'm like the hardest hitter
like yeah i have never met like
most people that hit pads with are in
this in the fight business say that i'm
like at the top level of like you know
powerful punching you know
um but man i've talked to friends and
colleagues who are millennials who their
whole lives it's been drilled into their
minds men and women are exactly the same
there's no difference whatsoever and
they will they will get angry with me
and they'll say michael what do you mean
men will almost always beat women you
know physically what do you mean that's
so sexist that's so backwards
you know it's just some women are going
to beat some men and it's like men and
women are basically this so it's
obviously there are exceptions no one's
saying there aren't exceptions oh i'm an
exception you're an exception i'm an
exception but like not
like if you've got like if you break it
down to experience weight class and
everything um it's yeah not even close
no i don't think so
we both got that right yeah no drinking
yeah i'm sorry to say i still want a
drink this is like that i know this is
especially at this point in the game
where the temptation yeah plus i have to
catch up a little bit my yeah
okay all right ready
wait was that your way of saying
i'm losing i think you might be losing i
think this might have shifted shoot
we will not have true equality until we
can safely identify as beep bop boop
without fear of cancellation
seems like a pointed question
we will not have true equality until
true equality
yes yes of course yes of course you
can't
true equality i mean i'm sorry not true
equality is a very different thing but
the way that people talk about equality
these days is true or everyone's exactly
the same yeah the only way you can have
it is if nothing makes sense anymore
because that means you can't even
identify any differences but everyone's
different yeah there's a agreed of life
yes i agreed yeah we agree on that beep
bop boop we didn't lose okay
we need to look maybe we should throw
the next round you know yeah the way we
can drink yeah
all right
yeah right i'm competitive i want to win
we will get some answers from the i
never say her name right um we will get
some answers from the jizzlane maxwell
trial is that i think it's elaine oh i
don't i don't so just lane is not it
it's sort of a funnier way to pronounce
it but
i think it might be like i've been
saying that for two years oh my gosh
well that's all right because that just
it just proves you don't know her which
is your credit oh yeah obviously but
like
honestly i've been saying that for two
years hey you learned something every
day you know oh gosh yeah
well it comes how do you say it uh gee
lane elaine okay so maybe i've been
saying
gizlane gislane just lane i just need to
get rid of the s all together just
laying it okay okay
you can say michael told you yeah
he taught me you taught me something
very valuable here um we will get some
answers from the
gilain maxwell trial we will get some oh
you just wanted to drink
there's no way we're never gonna get any
answers from that trial there's no do
you think we might i think that
lies and corruption have a really
interesting way of coming to the surface
even if it's five or ten years so yeah i
think it'll come out eventually so we
both lost yeah thank goodness i know i
was getting the shakes you don't think
so
oh
i think it's so crooked i think
going back
all the way to the first episode epstein
prosecution you've got the u.s attorney
alex acosta was then up uh labor
secretary for trump and uh he hears
sorry uh epstein belongs to
intelligence us intelligence and that's
and he reported this then at the time he
was up for labor secretary
uh then he gets this sweetheart deal
he's basically you know checks in in the
morning at the palm beach county jail
and then goes off and does whatever he
wants and then hillary clinton i'm sorry
then somebody then he commits suicide
i'm sorry he committed suicide is what
happened
committed suicide
i don't know anything
so that anyway that happens and
all of a sudden elaine maxwell gets
arrested and but for some reason it's
closed off you can't see anything that's
going on the reports are pretty weak
coming out of there her black book is
totally sealed and it just so happens
that all the richest and most powerful
men around the world don't have their
identities exposed
i don't know i do think though
that you know just how you see those
documentaries come out later um like 5
10 20 25 years i do think eventually
especially how curious and inquisitive
people are right now
i feel like people are just thirsty to
understand what's really going on and so
there's a part of me that really wants
to believe in this time that we're going
to find out answers no matter what
not just like about that trial but
what has taken place in the last two and
a half years we need to know
in order to move forward and make a
better world we need to break it down to
what happened and what's happening
and that's going to mean like a lot of
people need to be held accountable yeah
that well this is the issue because when
corruption is
more or less ubiquitous
a lot of people have a lot of incentives
not uh not to let that out but i think
you you are right i think of uh
lbj stole his senate seat in 1948 and
then he becomes vp and then he becomes
president united states and then we only
could really prove that he stole the
seat people suspected at the time we
only only really prove it i think in 91
or 92 so it
it took over 40 years but it did come
out it did come out it did come out
you're right but it does happen we'll
find out about what bill gates i think
you should drink again because i made a
good point you made an excellent point
we're gonna get way creepier bill
clinton photos from the island yeah like
30 years yeah that's okay yeah cause
blackmail is the currency in politics
and somebody's got all of that
you're right okay now i'm up that was
such a good point it was a great point
gina this is my i will say this this is
my favorite episode we've ever uh
it is this is great okay
there is absolutely nothing concerning
about otherwise healthy young adults
coincidentally suffering strokes and or
facial paralysis after taking a
perfectly safe and effective
experimental injection are we even
allowed to answer this or we're going to
get booted off of youtube cancelled
twice
so okay so the statement is there is
absolutely nothing concerning or out of
the ordinary about otherwise healthy
young adults just coincidentally
suffering strokes and facial paralysis
and all sorts of things after taking the
perfectly
safe experimental injection wow
yes thinking both
we're both on the same page with that i
think so yeah i think so it's absolutely
mind-boggling how we're not allowed to
talk about it no um
they've got like accidental
uh adult death syndrome and um yeah and
then we've got like you know uh
athletes just
dropping dead dropping like flies and
like the delusion and like the refusal
to admit that this
could be related is it just to even like
raise the question it makes my blood
boil
we we now know even the people pushing
all this stuff they will now admit that
certain vaccines cause heart problems
certain vaccines cause blood clots
they'll admit they'll say it's very rare
though so i had a relative of mine who's
very liberal she says oh michael you
know covid's a very big deal my friend's
father got kovid
and uh
and then he got the vaccine like six
months later he got the vaccine and then
a week later he died of a heart attack
and i said oh well
so you're kind of proving my point that
maybe we should be cautious with the
vaccine she goes oh no it wasn't the
vaccines it was kovit six months ago
like what is that how do you not like
you just put something into your body
for in two weeks prior
or whenever and you know say no i think
it was you know three years ago i walked
across the street right that's probably
what it was did more admit like oh i've
got a drinking problem before this
vaccine is like the problem you know you
know i i do my only drinking problem is
we keep getting these answers right so
we can't i know that's my problem too
you're up
let's get some wrong shall we okay
in general women in real life and in
movies have
stormtrooper level accuracy when it
comes to shooting guns
i feel so like
in tune with the
star wars right now because i get that
joke
so this is in this is saying in real
life or just in movies um and yeah in
general women in real life and in movies
have storm trooper level accuracy when
it comes to shooting guns yeah so okay
so not not always on target yeah not not
great uh-huh okay
um
do you agree with that michael well yeah
we're about to figure that out we are um
[Music]
and i did just watch a terrific movie
you're in where a lot of bullets fly and
they don't always hit their target okay
in that movie
i'm just they even make a reference in
that movie they're like and tara and the
prairie they make a reference they're
like ah she's an awful shot
i'm answering yes for you for me for you
you think i think women are just awful
shots in general mm-hmm
that's i'm just stuck it's just like a
reverse psychology like you want me to
put yes as well are you trying to get
this wrong maybe
maybe maybe not there's no way
where are you from
new york new york yeah
oh gosh
you agree with that
i haven't said anything yet why are you
you think i agree with that so here's
what i'll tell you oh no you can tell me
why you drink
wait so i'm so i got that wrong
but you know what gina you actually got
that right you got it right because
here's the thing i am inclined to think
that women are not great shots
i mean these women don't go to the range
that much i think you know i go to the
range i see it's about 99.7
dudes and then maybe there is that lady
in the corner yeah but i will say the
best shot i know
is a chick yeah and she could out shoot
all of us it's crazy like i took my mom
and
to a shooting range and you just put a
gun in her hand and she she was like a
better shot on the first try than me and
i was like
i've been practicing like she was so i
know it because gun i mean this is
actually one of the arguments for the
second amendment is guns are an
equalizer yeah as you say women are at a
physical disadvantage if men are trying
to fight them i
would have got in their hand i feel so
much more comfortable when i have my gun
on me
especially in the last two and a half
years i just feel like you know
i mean i broke down on the road in the
middle of arizona at a ghost town i was
like i'm good i had like a a knife and a
gun on me i'm like all right let's go
we're gonna make terror in the prairie
too
yeah in arizona modern version what do
you shoot
um nine millimeter beretta beretta
that's the greatest gun company ever you
know i clicked with that one yeah so but
i would say it's really um it makes me
feel more comfortable with my mom my
grandma my grandma has like a gun with a
pink handle on it and i'm like good i'm
glad yeah of course do you know beretta
is such an old gun company they
outfitted the holy league at the battle
of lepanto in 1571
where the much smaller western christian
forces totally destroyed the muslim
turks with facts and logic and also with
their beretta cannons wow
that's a great
and they're beautiful guns they're
really beautiful guns and they're smooth
and they're smooth yeah i'm basically i
just want beretta to sponsor my show
sponsored by you're a listener
[Laughter]
okay
i'm up
i've watched deadpool
haywire
and fast and furious six
but you've had to have you you had to
have watched all three it's and no you
didn't
[Music]
no you did so i'm gonna
obviously you've
see you didn't you didn't necessarily
have to watch them
but you have you go to the premiere you
go to the red carpet people say gina
carano is here you go you watch the
rings
really yep no
which one haven't you seen deadpool
deadpool really
that was one of the ones i have seen i
haven't seen haywire yet even though i
heard it was great i wouldn't have
thought you would have watched deadpool
i oh of course oh no i you know i hate i
hate the superhero movies
but deadpool is cool it's great of the
superhero movies i i see almost none of
the other ones
deadpool's a great it's a great place it
is it's really good but you're still
wrong i know i have to drink uh did you
yeah i know i never watched deadpool i
never watched um season two of
mandalorian i wouldn't have watched
normally tara on the prairie um i try to
stay away from watching i you know
eventually i'll watch it in my life
maybe
why is it that some actors have no
problem some actors will
analyze themselves you know they're
really into it and then some actors
can't watch themselves on screen they
just i just think that um
i think i'm really really critical and i
also it's like i
unless i'm doing it to study and get
better which i do do that
but
it just it makes me
feel too vulnerable
yeah yeah it's true i i eventually watch
it but it hurts
my soul
is it are you sort of second guessing
like
why'd they use that take or oh i did it
better or is it yeah i mean all that
stuff is going but i just i'm really um
critical of like i see myself too much
and i want to not um
it's not an enjoyable experience i used
to i used to never watch my fights as
well i eventually started watching that
and i was like hey that was actually
pretty good
you know i wonder if it's because
most people who are going to watch tara
on the prairie or any other movie that
you're in they don't know you personally
yeah so you're you are the character
they can lose themselves
but you
you know yeah you know you're not some
19th century lady shooting guns out of
windows you know you know you're gina
caron and i just always want to do so
much better you know so i'm like i'm
just really hard yeah it's hard for me
to watch sounds like a mentality of a
fighter actress yeah there's a little
bit of a competitive yeah i just want to
do better so but in reality if i watch
it i probably would get better and
better so i'm starting to accept it but
no i've never seen deadpool wow okay
you're up
uh-oh here we go okay
in a daily wire mma tournament that
included jeremy boehring candace owens
andrew clavin matt walsh and michael
knowles michael knowles would have the
worst odds to win the worst odds to win
hmm really so hold on who's in it
jeremy candice
andrew matt
michael
you
hmm
you they're saying you you said i'd have
the worst odds of that entire crew hmm
it's mm-hmm
it's quite the crew yeah
answer how you're going to answer gina
you know i don't
don't take into account my feelings
it's really difficult
i think is it is it gina
looks like she can get mean
she's a killer yeah she looks like she
couldn't really like she'd be biting
at least andrew you know he's looks like
he's got like that i don't know new york
do you have you ever seen his nose his
nose is kind of yeah
that's a nose that's been broken like
five or six times that guy has scrapped
and matt walsh is kind of like a serial
killer vibe right yeah he's a stone
called cereal yeah you say in that movie
and what is a woman the guy
no
totally it's amazing i love it plus he's
built like a lumberjack and he dresses
like one yeah so he's got that serial
killer vibe and and jeremy's just laser
beams super smart yeah
so smart without game you yeah yeah i
feel like and me what about me we've now
gone through well
yeah okay all right okay so the question
is uh-huh would you oh gosh this is uh i
have to answer it i've already answered
for you now you you can answer from me
right
so you
are looking at yourself
in the situation with your crushing
honesty junior without any this is you
or delusions of grandeur yeah without
any ego with true humility
okay
um
for you
just trying to play that psychology game
i think that you would say yes did i get
your answer right um yes
i'm going to drink anyway i think
i'm going to choose to drink anyway
look that is really tough competition
they
you
literally all of my coworkers yeah no i
know
it is it is no but you're like they're
talking you are the
the nicest thank you one
you know what they say nice guys finish
first right well actually nice people
are like the scariest so if i would have
applied that
um
okay okay well unfortunately
we both got that right yes
oh okay we did
now because you know that about yourself
because you're yes you're nice all right
thank you and you told me the crap
oh my gosh it's like a dagger in my
heart i want to be a killer i want to be
a thug
you know like a gangster
i'm like ray liotta and goodfellas i
always wanted to be a gangster you know
yeah um we'll work on that
we can work on that
it's going to take a it's going to take
some work no i'm kind of questioning it
now though okay all right
uh
there is absolutely nothing suspicious
about a gunman firing one round into oh
my gosh all right this is one all right
i'm gonna read until the end of this one
okay
there is absolutely nothing suspicious
about a gunman firing one round into a
washington dc pizza
ping pong parlor and only hitting the
hard drive of a computer in the back
room there is a crazy wild crazy
conspiracy theory okay
that this pizza parlor and ping pong
parlor
that a lot of extremely creepy people
are associated with pizzagate is that
yeah but the youtube rules no you can't
you would no one would ever promote this
like crazy totally nuts insane nothing's
wrong with this pizza place so we only
we just have to answer how the other one
would and then not give any verbal
confirmation if the other one got it
right okay
but no don't answer
you better not answer gina we'll get
kicked off of youtube
no answers
and i won't answer either well we don't
have to we're answering by not drinking
right that's right okay
that's good that's right dude that might
have gotten let's get out all right last
question censored
okay
publicly espousing music
perfectly as fasting woke ideology on
twitter is the modern day casting couch
wait
wow
wow that's deep
that's deep publicly as fasting woke
ideology on twitter is the modern day
casting coach
wow
wow
yep
you know better than i do
i mean i've never been on a casting
couch and i've
i don't plan on it so yes but that truly
these days if you do not
it truly it truly is hey you want the
part yeah it sure would be nice if you'd
tweet out this logo that was an
excellent statement that is wow that's
deep that comparison is amazing um
yeah like nowadays it doesn't have to be
physical contact it could just be i'm uh
i'll do anything for this
and that's the biggest problem you know
in ancient athens they had this idea
that seduction was worse than rape
and the argument here was that rape is
merely a physical violation but
seduction is an intellectual violation
as well
and there's a i think a comparison here
you know the old casting couch
kind of goes back to the the world's
oldest profession
but when they make you
lie
when they make you
discard everything that you believe
just to get the part in a way
it's it's deeper it's
that is such a great analogy wow wow so
good that even though we both got it
right we're going to finish it
to your health gina thank you
this was so fun
great really my favorite episode i don't
know who won
[Laughter]
thank you for tuning in to yes or no
tune back next time i think
given the way this game went i might
have sobered up by then and make sure
you get uh your own version of the game
at home yes or no available
dailywear.com
shop
we'll see you next time also there are
no rules
[Music]